Hey everyone, Trace here.
A Biologist and an Astronomer go to dinner.
That’s not the start of a joke, but it is
actually how that astronomer got the inspiration
for a new way of thinking about the stars.
That astronomer was the University of Cambridge’s
Dr. Paula Jofré, and she realized that she
could chart stars in the milky way the same
way we chart the family tree of animal species.
She and a team picked 22 stars (including
our sun) and observed their chemical makeup,
their age, and their movement to plot them
on a stellar “tree of life.”
They found that the stars they looked at could
be plotted on three branches of the tree,
with a few miscellaneous ones that didn’t
fit with the others.
They can tell which stars are related based
on their chemical makeup, almost like their
stellar DNA.
If they were born in the same gas cloud then
their makeup would be similar.
This study found 8 of stars they looked at
were the sun’s siblings.
The researchers also suggested some of the
stars may have originated from another galaxy
that was absorbed by the Milky Way.
Of course, they only looked at 22 of 100 billion
stars, so maybe those 6 that didn’t fit
with the others have some long lost brothers
and sisters out there.
The more they look, the more complete our
galaxy’s tree of life will be.
Jofré’s goal is to get astronomers to think
about the history of stars in a new way, so
if you’re an astronomer don’t be afraid
to take a scientist from a different field
out to dinner.
It’s not so much a tree of life as maybe
a spiral, which is appropriate considering
we do live in a spiral galaxy.
To learn how it got its shape, check out this
video here.
Has one branch of science taught you something
you didn’t expect about another branch?
Let us know in comments, make sure you subscribe
and come back here for more videos.